Hãy bà, hai mình chỉnh tuổi quay ở tình kết lâm, Trung Quốc sinh ra trong một dây định làm nông.
Bỏ hợp năm 2018, anh đến tình phố Chương Sơn làm phủ bếp trong một nhà hàng,
làm thử hàng trong sự ổ tốt, kiếm được băng hình đếm bộ nghìn đệ,
bốn chăm năm sau trong U.S.D. một tháng.
Vô lấy vợ năm 2018 và năm 2018, họ xinh con trải phủ dây dược.
Vợ ở nhà trong con, buồn kiếm tình đôi sống gia đình.
Tình phạm, anh chánh thủ thử dân trời với con và phát hiện xức khỏe con trải không tốt,
hai định á vào kêu mệt đổi bố bếp.
Họ phát hiện con trải mắc mạnh mật cầu năm 2018, bình á tổ tháng.
Vô đưa con trải vào viện kiến trắc khi thấy việc bẩm tím ở trên của bếm máy không khỏe.
2 vợ trong đưa con đi thiền tình trở bệnh,
nhưng người nói bệnh của giây dược không kỳ chứ hỏi, nhưng anh tấn kiên chỉ, tôi không muốn hủ tiết,
tôi cứ tâm trở hỏi bệnh trời con trải dụ của phải tán gia bại sản, bu vô bệnh tỏe.
Sơn đó, bu bản nhà, bay mự khắp nơi để trắng trải phí phí chữa bệnh trời con.
Sau hai năm, tình trạng của giây dược khá hơn, câu bếc có thể ăn uống bình thường.
Họ quy định đưa con về trường xuân để đối tù cánh, 2 vợ trong ở nhà bệnh vợ.
Giây dược đi học bỗng giáo, nhưng hay bị sốt nên nghĩ học sau vài tháng.
Họng thưa ra ở nhà là thêm vui vệnh nhất của cậu bếnh.
Bốn này, bay đời chờ bố đi làm về lúc đối đêm với sự đi ngủ.
Giây dược tích được bố ông vào làm, hay bố đề trải và mữa ước lối lên làm cạnh rất để bảo vệ bố.
Tháng tư năm nay, ngày khu chăm ha nếu mốt, bình vệ ở phía tân dục gia đình đưa ra dự vĩnh kiểm tra lại xứ khỏe,
chỉ vì hàng trục nghiên nhân dân tệ.
Thật nãy cả nước đặc phong toạ vì COVID-19 các người hàng đều đón cửa.
Mất mỗi tuy nhập, vô không biết lấy đấu gia tình được còn đi khám.
Một người bạn gọi định chỉ cho vô cách kiểm tiền.
Anh ấy từng làm người thu gong phê liệu, mới tơi rằng có thể lấy đồng trong mấy bình khác đêm bán lấy tình, vô nói.
Tô sinh nghĩ mấy ngày, tôi phải đưa con đến tiến tân để kiểm tra vào tháng mấy.
Tô không còn lựa chọn nào khác ngoài đồng ý.
Bố cùng bạn xuống khu vực nông thu, chụi hơn 20 mấy bình ác, bán được trưa tới 8 mi nhìn dân tệ,
bố nghiên 2 chăm đối lắm ý.
Tơi thằng sau, anh bị bắt bả bị kết 1,5 tuy vị tối phá hoạn.
Tháng 1 năm, anh y hi khu chăm ha nếu bà, người nhà đưa bẻ xe dựa vào tụ thăm vụ.
COVID-19 sâu lưng bằng hoạn, nhưng anh vẫn nhìn thấy đồng và mặt mối con tra xương tò vía uống thu lâu mẫu tài phát.
Cô khoảng lý trẻ ra 30 kênh lâm và cả mộ nhà tụi cùng bạn tụi quyến góp được bệm mi nhìn dây,
chính nghiên bày 20 mấy dân lắm ý, giúp anh nhìn chi phí này như bối bỏ bệ, buồn nói.
Năm thằng sau, tình trạng của xe dựa thương, vừa của vô vào tụi, sinh cho trường vào vị thang con.
Một thằng sau, bẻ ra dựa qua đời không anh xam bảo tin cho vụ.
Hí cho mẹ và anh trải tới thăm anh, họ luôn nói cầu mẽ đang vui vụ tốt,
tôi cảm nhận được con trải khu quay như người nhà giấu ví dựa tôi chăm cảm, anh kể lại.
Tham mấy một năm anh y hú chăm thằng anh, anh mới hay tin con trải qua đời khí có phòng viên đến phòng bấn,
vô gảo thét không tin.
Cháng xưa đó và thăm cho biết dựa dạ dạy cho khu quốc mẽ về đầm tính quyết cân nhà tụi của vô,
mời cầu mẽ muốn ở vấn đô.
Sau khi bố ra tụi, đường như con, hay đến đầm tính quyết,
có luôn ở đó, bố anh chuyên đặt lời của zẻ dựa.
Bố được giảm anh bày thẳng tụi và ra tụi thằng mấy một năm anh y hú chăm thằng mi tư.
Anh quay về chương sân tìm việc làm, cứ nửa thẳng lại tới đầm tìm quyết thăm con.
Vô lập một tệ khoản mạng xa hội, chia sẻ cuộc sống và tu hút hàng chục nghiệp với thế gió.
Tình tra như nguy, nhưng các làm lại sai, khi vòng kým xo họ vẫn là chắc con,
mừng người có tin ký hoàn bình luật.
Anh ấy không phải là cung dân tốt, như là người chát tự vời, mừng người khác bày tỏ.